lock him to this video playing Egyptian
tiger and I guess from Egypt right yeah
this is this even possible a tiger in
Egypt I don't think so maybe in a zoo
but not in the nature and okay let's
let's do this image avoid change okay
yeah this is normally helping white to
have h6 provoked simply because you you
win a temple I'm not attacking it at the
moment due to the sinaitic c4 trick um
so let's say place c6 if i take this 94
with Queen age for getting it back but
then at some stage she needs to address
the pawn and this some means that I'm
winning a temper this is a fun way okay
tempting me into into capturing I don't
I won't do that um the question is what
should i do actually maybe castling long
now I'm attacking it what I will take it
I'm one of those guys who will take
pawns okay going for counter-attack so
hmm okay what does this idea maybe
Knight b6 them might be six might might
be a might be an idea to go to c4
hmm okay so should I move this night to
g3 for example on or maybe d5 many many
tempting moves actually it's before an
issue I don't know I can go to d5 if
this is probably not so so much of a
problem ok on Knight b6 i'm going to
play Knight g3 i wanted to have G for
played first so that Nigeria then h4 h5
is an idea I don't quite know what you
should do maybe still Knight b6 I didn't
want to take I don't want to take on b5
ever be opening up his beef I'll yeah
this should be ok i always have been
three yeah if you go see six i take on
g7 and then 93 ok now i will take here
first and i can take with the Queen a
bit wait just for a moment I take with
the night I've got 96 and the in the mix
are still jackets it's with a check
that's very helpful and now just H for
you giacomo the queen is just excellent
onda form
yes but if I go can I just play emme i
guess i can he can take here but i have
h 5 I just want to open up the position
yeah can win win this tempo I can do he
can win c4 hmm that's not good
yeah that was not necessary I didn't say
I didn't see that c4 was also attacked
but still term it should be quite good
g5 meow g5g five and h5 immediate h5 he
might play g5 I didn't want to allow
that yeah it was very sloppy play giving
up see form
he might play b3 here Wow b3 intending
92 maybe I must do something like that
well I really sport this check all right
i mean i don't think something our c4
hangs I don't think something really
terrible was happening but it was it was
not really necessary to allow most of
that yeah i still have h5 coming like
this in his no there is no there's no
attack via those pawns just block likes
way to my king I can take he actually
Queen f2000 medium no let's made with 97
check checkmate that's quite nice yeah I
just I just didn't didn't realize that
c4 was saying I was relaxing a bit too
earlier in the position is excellent for
white but it was was was just very
sloppy to give it away here when the
computer still says white is completely
winning okay yeah maybe it is so
overwhelming that it does not matter
yeah it's still a complete win yeah but
i didn't i didn't really I didn't really
realize so what what I did hear that I
gave away c4 it's probably
many ways to improve but he just gave
away h6 this is this is the make the
main point you must do something here
maybe age 5 it's not ideal you don't
want to weaken you on your king site
here but ok what what else what else is
is this what do what else should you do
so we must do that until I'm basically
winning right out of the opening it's a
it's just too much 94 is also a good
move always hard to tell but this is
just just strong very very big space
advantage and attack on the King side
alright thanks for watching